joining me now one of my favorites of
all time he is brian balding her Baldy
one of the best NFL analysts in the
business one of my partners in crime at
NFL Network played for the Cowboys the
Colts and the Eagles called games for
Fox he's calling games on the radio he's
calling games on TV does college
football does NF a Baldy are everywhere
what are you doing right now at this
very moment I just got done studying
Stephane Gilmore
right now Helle he's the best corner in
football right now and I'm trying to
think if he's the best since Darrelle
Revis was in his prime because that's
how he's playing the game right now he's
a big cornerstone to the best defense in
this league by far and maybe the best
defense we've seen in a long time I'm
glad you brought that up because we
talked about this a little bit earlier
this team this this is Tom Brady's team
but it's driven by the defense very
similar to those early Super Bowl
winning teams with Brady the head
brewski and Willie and Vrabel on it you
talked about this line backing core and
you compared the line back in court of
the Golden State Warriors why well
because they they're really they really
play multiple all of them play multiple
positions it doesn't matter you're
talking about Jamie Collins right now
who leads the team in tackles or Donte
Hightower or Kyle van Noy or Roberts you
know I mean John Simon right now I mean
they played every linebacker on the
roster last night and they they they can
play inside they can play outside they
can stand up they can rush they can run
twists stunts I mean III compare them
because Golden State has sort of defined
what position less basketball is where
anybody can handle the ball anybody can
run the brake and that's kind of how
right now New England is playing defense
I mean there's such interchangeable
parts that you really can't key on one
guy right now Dan Haley filling in for
Rich Eisen on the Rich Eisen show with
Brian balding or on the phone right now
allowing 6.8 points per game going into
last night one offensive touchdown
allowed tonight you said it's the best
defense we've seen in a long time could
this be the best since the 85 Bears I
know they don't have kind of that the
headliners the big names but Stephon
Gilmore certain
falls in that category guys I mean you
got to think about you know the Ravens
of 2001 you know they were a great
defense and they were probably the best
since the Bears and I played on some
Eagle teams with in 91 and 92 which was
the best in football but right now if
you just looked at my mean they're
literally number one statistics on every
single category except for run defense
but I mean they lead the league and
takeaways and interceptions and sacks we
have 25 sacks right now Dan in the first
six games I mean just prorate that and
you're gonna hit somewhere around the 70
numbers right now and they just do the
best job right now of marrying their
coverage with the variety of twist
stunts in the way that they rush to pass
or they might not have a guy on the team
that gets double digits and sacks they
rarely do but they don't care about that
I mean the linebackers have 16 of the 25
sacks there's more than enough to go
around with it the way that they
basically make the quarterback hold the
ball the way we saw dan daniel Jones
hold the ball last night but it's been
every single week they make the
quarterback hold the ball and they'll
play just sticky tight man coverage with
the robber in the middle of the field a
variety of coverages but the foundation
is man coverage with twists stunts up
front they took down everybody the
postseason last year shutting out
Patrick mahomes in that first half
keeping the Rams to three points and
it's all carried on into this season the
other undefeated team in the NFL right
now the San Francisco 49ers big game for
the 49ers this weekend here in LA taken
on the three and two Rams San Francisco
Baldy the only team in the NFL with a
top five total offense scoring offense
top five total defense scoring defense
this is the 49er team we've been waiting
to see since Kyle Shanahan got in town
and look they lead the league in rushing
and I think you know the run game
coordinator Mike McDaniels is a guy that
has filed college Shanahan everywhere
he's ever been starting in Houston
Washington to Cleveland to Atlanta and
now out to LA and he's kind of a genius
in there in the way that they run the
ball is kind of genius now they're gonna
be without really key components this
week so they'll be short-handed no cows
view check
no mic McGlinchey you know joe staley
has been out for three weeks so you know
I mean there I got to see how they do it
now against a Rams defense that you know
has struggled quite a bit you know
especially going back to Tampa Bay and
then against against Seattle so maybe
you know and they've lost key players
too but yeah I mean in the number one
rush defense rushing offense and
football right now damn but you know
that defense line you know it was just
it was like Shark Week last Monday night
against the Cleveland Browns I mean
Baker Mayfield was a piece of chum and
they got after him and that's what John
Lynch has been building I mean they've
been you know drafting defensive linemen
high for a long time and now they got
them all on the field healthy right now
and if they if you can't run the ball
and bounce it out and do some things and
you let that defensive line just feast I
mean they'll get after Jared Goff if if
they can't balance it out and I think
Sean McVeigh knows that yeah I can't
wait to see that game if they if they
beat the Rams and I know this isn't the
same Rams team at least not yet that
they were last year do you have to start
calling the 49ers one of the top two
three teams the NFC well you gotta you
gotta put them in that you know in a
playoff hunt I mean if you think you get
to five and oh I mean they're gonna be
in that playoff picture
and you know they're doing things that
they do have never done under Kyle
Shanahan they're taking the ball away I
mean they had seven takeaways all of
last year they have more than that right
now they could intercept the ball last
year I mean they're doing that and that
all starts up front but yes I mean you
can definitely if they're five you know
and they go through what they've just
done you know whether it's Cleveland on
Monday night and the Rams this this
weekend Dan I mean there's certainly one
of the top three or four teams in the
NFC I have to ask you about the Rams I
don't want to focus too much on this
game but to me this is the most
interesting game of the weekend for the
first time in the mcveigh era it just
feels like there's uncertainty with this
Rams offense the offensive line is
struggling Todd Gurley we don't know
what the situation is in terms of him
playing this week because of the quad
Jared Goff has ten giveaways more than
any other quarterback in the NFL this
year when you're breaking down the tape
what are you seeing that's not going
right for this Rams offense right now
they're not getting the big
plays that they're used to getting I
mean they've been up the top two or
three in the league and big chunk plays
and they're not getting those and then I
think right now I think there's just a
huge disparity I mean they've run they
thrown the ball over a hundred times
more than they run it in the first five
weeks of the season we saw you know when
Jared Goff threw the ball well over 60
times against Tampa now they were
playing from behind but I mean they ran
the ball 11 times that day and so
they've gotten away from Todd Gurley and
and all the things that Todd Gurley has
been known for since Shaun McVeigh got
there you know I mean just been a great
all-around player and he has not been
that type of player right now he's got a
big part of the passing game in fact
he's averaging less than five yards of
catch and we're used to seeing big
screens and all that now they're
replacing two offensive linemen you know
from a year ago in a Super Bowl run and
an offensive line that started the same
line for 19 straight weeks in a season
I'm not putting anything on what they're
getting from Brian Allen at Center or
Joseph nope boom at left guard but
they're not the same group up front
right now and I think the quarterback is
struggle a little bit when they're
putting it all on him to throw it all
around the yard to win these games and
these you know you mentioned the 10
turnovers that's that's far too many
from that position
Brian balding or joining the Rich Eisen
show Dan Hally filling in for rich now
Baldy on your baldies breakdown she
focused a little bit on the Saints our
producer Dom Bowie big Saints fan I
think he wanted me to ask a Saints
question here so I'm gonna go ahead and
yeah Teddy Bridgewater I'm driving in
I'm a big deal I'm a big Tom Bowie fan
I'm driving in I'm listing a little
sports talk radio and I hear all these
guys and Bridgewater's been great
Mellisa he hasn't lost the game but I
don't I don't think Bridgewater's been
great I think he played better his last
game bridge is Bridgewater starting NFL
quarterback right now yeah I mean I mean
wait play last week he is but what the
Saints I mean you go back to the win in
Seattle you know you go back to what
they did against Dallas you look back at
what they did last week
you know they define what a team is all
about I mean the offense line
pitched a shutout last week
you know they I mean literally teddy
bridgewater wasn't hit I mean that Shack
bear coming in who leads the league in
sacks with nine and forced fumbles and
all that stuff and he didn't you know he
wasn't even breathing on teddy
bridgewater they shut him out you know
and then Michael Thomas looked like
Michael Thomas last week I mean he's
unstoppable he's his Twitter handle is
can't guard Mike and they couldn't guard
Mike and Alba camara is and I'm just an
unselfish player the full-back Zac line
is an unselfish player and defensively
they might be the best defensive line of
football all around I mean when you talk
about shutting down as equal Elliot for
less than two yards to carry two weeks
ago you go and see how they defended
Russell Wilson in Seattle you go and
look at you know how they just
completely dominate the line of
scrimmage last week against Tampa you
know and then you look at Marshall on a
lotta more you know he wants to go
matchup against the best he did it
against Amari Cooper shut him down he
went up against Mike Evans and others
last week they shut him down so right
now their defense is playing as well as
anybody in football including the
Patriots but so it's just a total team
effort and and you know okay no no to
Brees no problem because they really
defined what a team is all about
everybody has stepped up everybody has
improved as a team since to Brees went
down that's really impressive what
they've been able to do and it I think
it just goes to show how important
backup cubies are right we've seen it in
recent history like we have this year
you know 10 different backup
quarterbacks have started a game this
year through week 5 the most intriguing
to me I think you know where I'm going
here Baldy Gardner Minshew
he's too into the whole the whole deal
to stash the outfits the swag and Kyle
Allen who hasn't lost a game both are
top 10 in passer rating Minshew has 9
touchdown passes in a pick this year
Kyle Allen hasn't thrown an interception
in three starts I got an up close and
look at Kyle Allen I called his game
against the Cardinals which one of these
guys if you had to roll the rest of the
way with one of them meant you or Allen
which one would you choose you know the
reason why I'm even hesitating I mean I
think the obvious one is Mitchell but
the reason why I'm even hesitate
is what north turner has done and
allowed for Kyle Allen to succeed now
you saw him against the Cardinals and
Cole net game at Fox Danny you know you
saw that touchdown pass before the end
of the first half to deejay more I mean
he he rifled that ball in the middle of
the field and the jaws of the Arizona
defense and hit more in stride and he
can finish as well as anybody in this
business in stride with his with his
speed and with his strength 52 yards
later I mean they had the Cardinals I
mean it was over but if you look at what
North Turner's doing right now I mean
you can easily say and make a case you
know that Christian McCaffrey is the MVP
of this business and he leads the league
in rushing he leads the league in total
yards from scrimmage and you know North
Turner's doing a great job of just game
planning and basically calling plays to
get Christian McCaffrey just isolated in
space like he did on the 18 yard
touchdown pass last week he's just
isolated against Myles Jack and Carl
Allen you know throws up a five yard
pass McAfee finishes in the paint nor
was really doing a great job I think
with Kyle he's not he's not forcing the
ball down the field
he's not putting them in bad positions
and so they'll get tested this week you
know they'll have a rematch game with
Tampa Bay we'll find out a little bit
more about Kyle Allen
but Minshew has been unbelievable he
really has I mean I come back win at
Denver I played at Denver seven times
and I never won a game up there I mean
that place is impossible to play in it's
just it's it's loud and you can't
breathe you get tired quickly I mean he
goes up there and has a comeback win
against Denver and I know what Denver is
and all that stuff but it still it's
impressive to see what he is doing and
what he continues to do he had a chance
to win that game last week all the way
to the very end so you know it in the
backup quarterbacks I mean that's the
one of the big themes of this season and
I think a lot of teams are gonna go gosh
I wish we would have invested in a guy
like Teddy Bridgewater or drafted a guy
like you know Gardner Minshew
and you know because we're gonna see
more guys go down before the seasons out
yeah we could see another backup
quarterback getting some run for the
Steelers quickly Baldy before we let you
go I just want to put you on the spot
here the way to early MVP boat vote you
mentioned Christian McCaffrey
let's go McCaffrey mahomes or Russell
Wilson who do you have
can we flip a three-headed coin I mean
you can't really I mean I'm gonna see my
home's this week against Houston no we
just saw been held to 13 points by the
Colts did a good job of playing
keep-away and running the ball and keep
them off the field but I'm feeling he's
going to bounce back awfully fast this
weekend but I mean Russell Wilson was so
good the last time we saw him that you
almost have to say Russell Wilson at
this point with what Seattle is doing
yeah I think you're right just kind of
what he's working with and what he's
lost Russell Wilson continues to get it
done Baldy what game you doing this
weekend I will be in Kansas City we'll
see a great shootout between deshaun
Watson and Patrick mahomes I love it I
love it we don't have time to get to
that but that's another game we're gonna
focus on a little bit later in the show
baldies thank you so much for coming on
I really appreciate the time to talk to
you all right buddy I thought you two
alright men
that's Brian balding are one of the very
best in the business for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app